فقدمت نانسي شخصيه سمر الفتى السوريه اللي
بتنتقل للعيش في اسطنبول خلال فتره
الاحتلال العثماني
الطبيب اللي تم اغتياله فيه ظروف مشبوهه
سمر في المسلسل في الطابه تحمل على كتفه
اعباء الماضي وفي عندها نقمه على الحاضر
وما شاء الله غير العملين الضخمين اللي
ناسي منجمه فيهم كان عندها كمان عمل ثالث
هو مسلسل دوار شمالي وبتلعب فيه شخصيه
وداد لكن تم تاجيل عرض المسلسل لبعد رمضان
بسبب ظروف انتاجيه تنضم الينا من دمشق
الفنانه نانسي خوري اهلا فيك معنا يا
نانسي منوره هالرمضان
مساء الخير مساء الخير عليكم جميعا رمضان
كريم وشكرا كثير على الاستضافه نورتنا
علينا وعليك اول شيء خلينا بدي يعني
السؤال اللي عند الكل اذا حنبدا من الزند
اللهجه يا نانسي اللهجه كثير ناس بيتكلموا
انك اجدت اللهجه كيف
الحقيقه يعني سبقوا كنت عم بدرس كنت عم
بحاول اجمع فيني اكون مجتهده باني ادرسي
ادرس اللهجه لانه الحقيقه هي مثلها الواحد
عم يحكي لغه تانيه وهي كتير بعيده عني
فكان هيك تحدي كثير صعب بس انا برايي
الوقت يعني والممارسه تبع اللهجه مع الوقت
وبقلب فترات التصوير هي اللي كانت هيك شوي
شوي عم بتصير اللهجه اقرب وصلنا نقدر
نحكيها اكثر بس الحقيقه كانت صعبه ممتعه
كثير بس في نفس الوقت يعني اوريدي الواحد
لما يكون مثلا بيسوي شيء او بيحاول يتعلم
شيء صعب فما بالك انه هو بيتكلم بلهجه ما
هي لهجته وفي نفس الوقت جلس يمثل قد ايش
كان صعب عليك التركيز يعني في الشيال يعني
كتير صعب اكيد اول فتره كان صعب بعدين مع
الوقت من كثر ما انا بعيد الجمل بيني وبين
حالي فخلص بصيروا
بيهضمن الممثل فبتصير بقى بيمثل صعب وقت
كان يجتمع اكثر من لهجه مع بعض
كثير
او مصورته من قبل سنتين يمكن او صورتيه في
2020 يمكن
صورناه من السنتين تم تصويره اغلب يعني
اغلب تصويره صورناها بالقاهره بعدين
ببيروت من سنتين تقريبا
وانصدمتي السنه انه انعرض في نفس الوقت مع
الزند
قبل رحيله يعني الله يرحمه والله يعني
ما لحن التقى فيه قبل التصوير لانه توفى
الاستاذ حاتم
بفتره قصيره بس انا شغله مع استاذ حاتم
اعمال قبل من وقت ما تخرجت اول حمره معه
والعراب الجزء الاول والثاني كما كانوا مع
الاستاذ حاتم يعني انا شغله معه قبل وكنت
بتمنى لو يعني هيك عملت بس الله يرحمه
الله يرحمه
نانسي
النقاد والناس حتى جالسين بيقولوا انه هذه
السنه سنتك يعني الزند
وسفر برلك وقبلهم في ثمن قبلهم الثمن
الثمن مكسره الدنيا الثمن يعني دحين وقفوه
عشان رمضان نشاهد وام بي سي يعني وقفوه
رمضان بس كلنا بنستنى يخلص رمضان عشان
نرجع نشوف نكمل قصه الثمن
انت لما فعلا فعلا نفسك
هذه
استني في شيء عندك في الكونكشن يعني
سمعتك الان عيدي بس من الاول
بقول لك عيدي من الاول انه انتم هذه السنه
خلاص يعني فعلا انت حاسه انها سنتك مع
الثمن
يعني هلا الحقيقه ما بعرف يعني قصدي شو
فكره انه يعني انه فكره انه الواحد يكون
سنته بس يعني هي الاعمال هيك اجت وراء
بعضها والحمد لله هاي الاعمال اغلبها كانت
يعني ما زالت عم تنعرض هلا نزلت عم ينعرض
لسا فكانت عم تلاقي نجاح كثير كبير فهذا
الشيء هيك بيحقق يعني لالي
بيعطيني دفع لقدام للصراحه لحتى قولوا
وبعدين شو بدي اعمل يعني لسا بطريق طويل
هل صعبه اليوميه
صعب يعني
مو نجوميه صعب انه الواحد هيك يضل دائما
محافظ على الاستمراريه الحقيقه كتير صعب
ما بخفيك بدها كثير جهد وبدها صبر وبدها
يعني بدها وقت انا برايي كتير وقت لحتى
الواحد حافظ عليها والاعمال المشتركه
بتسهل الانتشار يمكن اكثر
اكيد اكيد طبعا طبعا يعني الثمن
مساحه كثير كبيره ولكن علمت الشخصيه
بخصوصيه دائما الشخصيات اللي بتكون شريره
او اشكاليه دغري العالم
بتتذكرها فعلمت الشخصيه وهيك يعني فيها
شيء وانا السعيده فيه هي الاختلاف بين
ثلاث شخصيات اذا بدنا نقول اذا عم نشوفهم
هلا كم شهر فهو في اختلاف كتير كبير
بيناتهم ايوه
واللي انا يعني بيحمسني اني
ضلعوا ابدا بعض العالم
موهبتك ما تحتاج يعني احد يتكلم عنها يا
نانسي فكل سنه وانت طيبه ودائما متالقه
وبنشكرك كانت معنا من دمشق الفنانه نانسي
خوري شكرا لك